Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim. Ja.
Na? Ja. Irgendwie irgendwas ist anders heute.
Der Ex-Parner ist anders.
Also ne ehrlich gesagt ist ja nicht sehr viel anders als sonst. Man muss da natürlich immer so ein bisschen dran drehen, aber das sollte uns jetzt nicht weiter verwirren. Aber, was natürlich ein bisschen verstörend ist, wir sind nicht allein.
Ja. Wir haben äh Publikum.
Ja, Publikum. Man merkt's, aber keine Gäste, keine Gäste.
Kommen ja noch sponta.
Ja, vielleicht ergibt sich ja noch irgendwie was.
Flitzer könnten wir eigentlich mal gebrochen.
Na, wir sind ja hier auch äh auf den Datenspuren in äh Dresden. Ist ja auch so eine Nordveranstaltung, die ja eigentlich alle so ein bisschen verkappte Dating äh treffen sind eigentlich, ne, ist da eigentlich,
das gesamte Nerdgeflecht in Deutschland eigentlich so ein verkappter Dating-Club. Ja. Findest du nicht auch?
Ja, da ist Unmengen an Sex in der Szene. Da ist boah.
Eine Menge Sex ist ja hier auch in diesem Podcast. Soll gleich mal äh eine Brücke zu schlagen,
Lokbuchnetzpolitik, Ausgabe Nummer einundvierzig und wie schon hier verschwurbelt, angedroht sind wir ausnahmsweise mal live von der Bühne äh hier in den Raum,
wie ich mir das so anschaue, handelt es sich weitgehend um einen rechtsfreien Raum und.
Nazifreiheit.
Auch das auch. Auf jeden Fall. Nazi und rechtsfreier Raum und äh wir haben ein Thema. Das ist neu, oder? Ich meine, das hatten wir nicht, dass wir noch nie Themen hätten, aber wir hatten noch nie in nur ein Thema.
Wir haben nur ein Thema, ja.
Genau, wir haben nur ein Thema.
Das Thema.
Das ist äh ah, ich dachte jetzt.
Schneller schneller.
Ich dachte, jetzt geht's um Sex. Also, dann geht's um Netzneutralität. Nee, nee, nee, lass mal bei Netzneutralität bleiben. Ich finde, das ist auch äh durchaus äh äh sexy genug.
Wolltest du nicht eigentlich einen Vortrag halten?
Sollen wir das, also ich wollte einen Vortrag halten, ja. Ich habe äh ich kann auch ganz kurz aber nur hier äh den Eingeweihten im Raum zeigen, warum ich den nicht halte,
weil ähm vor, also gestern Abend, so sahen irgendwie meine Folien aus,
Und dann habe ich gedacht, da wird nichts mehr. Und dann habe ich,
habe ich den habe ich gesagt, also theoretisch kann ich das ja erzählen alles, aber ich habe mit den Folien wirklichs und dann habe ich dem Tim eine DM geschrieben, hat gesagt, Tim, äh kannst du vielleicht bitte ähm ne und dann,
hat Tim gesagt, ja ich bringe da einfach.
Doch mal die ambulanten Geräte an.
Ich dachte, er kommt da mit so mit dem kleinen Task-Kamm, dann kam er hier mit so einem neunzehn Zoll Gerät. Das war auch gar kein Problem mit dem das der Transport war sicherlich gar kein Problem, so ein.
Es geht schon ganz gut. So, aber wir sind ja hier auch nicht zum Kleckern hier.
Nee, nee.
Ne? Ne. Ja, äh Netzneutralität, sperriges Thema. Ähm womit fangen wir denn an?
Ja, ich habe mir überlegt, wir fangen äh damit an, dass wir erklären, wie das wie was wir für ein Netz haben und wie das, wie das so zustande kommt. Und ähm ich denke ja, dass äh also Kinder fragen ja irgendwann im Laufe ihres Lebens immer die Eltern, ähm,
Mama, wo kommt irgendwie das Wasser her? Wo kommt der Strom her? Und irgendwann muss ein Kind, also jetzt, sage ich mal, deine Kinder werden irgendwann auch fragen,
Papa, wo kommt das Internet her.
Schweißausbruch und alles.
Ja und dann so, genau.
Gott, wie sag ich's dem Kinde?
Ja und dann man denkt irgendwie, das kommt aus der Wand, ne? Und das äh man hat da gibt's ein Kabel, das geht äh zur Telekom und da ist es irgendwo an den Rest des Internets drangestöpselt.
Und ähm so ungefähr ist das auch nur. Es gibt irgendwie das Internet ist ja nicht zentral, das heißt, es gibt nicht irgendwie so einen, einen,
wo man dann sagt, das ist der Internet und da stecken wir uns jetzt dran und dann können wir das äh den anderen geben. Sondern es gibt ganz, ganz viele verschiedene Firmen, die ähm irgendwie was irgendwie meinen, sie könnten was zum Internet beitragen oder auch nicht.
Und äh die sich dann so zusammenschließen und dann äh Verträge oder äh Agreements darüber treffen, wie sie gegenseitig mit ihrem Traffic umgehen.
Und dass man zum Beispiel sagt, ja, guck mal hier, ich habe zum Beispiel schon mal komplett Internet und ähm,
Du hast ja äh du hast ja da irgendwie ein paar hundert Kunden oder du willst tausende von Kunden haben, die da die an dieses Internet dran wollen,
Da machen wir irgendwie einen Vertrag darüber, ähm zu welchen Koalitionen wir beide uns mit einem Kabel verbinden. Und äh es gibt also, sage ich mal, die äh,
Stufe drei von von Providern, die also im Prinzip dem Internet wenig geben,
sondern nur äh das Internet irgendwo haben wollen, um es dann weiter zu verteilen. Es gibt dann äh Provider der Stufe zwei, die schon so ein bisschen überregionale Netzwerke haben. Und dann gibt's so die ganz Großen, äh die,
richtige Bag bei uns betreiben, die eigentlich nur noch große äh unterirdische Kabel irgendwo äh liegen haben und wirklich äh die Hochgeschwindigkeits.
Aber es gibt da jetzt keine äh äh offizielle Plakette, die man sich dafür äh abreichen lassen kann.
Nee, ich glaube, also man spricht immer so von Taya eins bis drei, aber ich habe eher den Eindruck, dass der Übergang so ein bisschen fließend ist. Ich meine, wenn du wirklich ja.
Drittes Rad am Wagen, Tier, meinst du? Tier, das ist eine sehr tierische Angelegenheit.
Ist das ist das wirklich, spricht man das Deutsch aus?
Nein, spricht man Englisch aus, aber es heißt dann halt immer noch Tier.
Echt? Guck mal, siehst du? Deswegen wollte ich den Tim habe ich ein Schwein, ja. Ähm.
Heißt ja ja hast du ein Schwein. Ja.
Die sagen also dann, OK, unter welchen Verbindungen legen wir ein Kabel? Also ähnlich wie ich das mit meinen Nachbarn mache, äh du willst mein Internet mitbenutzen, ja, kein Problem, ne? Dann haben gewissen Rechnungen, die ich bekomme und einen gewissen Anteil von dieser Rechnung, den ich dir weitergebe.
Hier eins, hier zwei, Tier drei.
Ich bin in dem Fall dann so T vier.
Sozusagen so eine Art Datenfauna.
Und ich bin das vierte Tier, weil ich noch unter dem Provider bin,
kann ich dann kann man also sagen, okay, man möchte, wenn man jetzt gleich viel zu bieten hat, gegenseitig, dann sagt man, okay, man möchte pearen. Das heißt,
ungefähr auf diesem Kabel, was man hat, was einen verbindet, äh wird ungefähr gleich viel in die eine äh als auch in die andere Richtung fliegen an Daten, die fliegen ja durch das Kabel durch,
und ähm dann äh wird das wird sich jetzt ungefähr ausgleichen. Wir brauchen da jetzt nicht abzurechnen. Und dann gibt's aber welche, die sagen, okay, wir machen Transit. Das heißt, äh je nach Bandbreite und Volumen kriegt derjenige, der da am anderen Ende sitzt, dann eine Rechnung geschickt.
Und in der Regel derjenige, der am anderen Ende sitzt, äh der bietet uns dann Flatrates an. Und ähm,
Hat also eine Rechnung schätzt, okay so und so viele Nutzer nutzen so und so viel Internet. Das heißt, äh Pi mal Daumen kann ich äh denen das Internet für so und so viel Euro anbieten. Und ähm dann sind alle glücklich und ich gebe denen, gibt denen eine Flatrate,
Und in der Regel sind diese Transit- und Peeringverbindungen, das ist quasi das das der Kern, der hintere Kern des Internets, von dem wir alle gar nicht so viel mitbekommen
so geschaltet, dass sie sagen das geht nach dem Best-Efford-Prinzip, das heißt, alles was da reingeballert wird, wird nach bestem Bemühen,
weitergeleitet, gleichbehandelt, da gibt's keine Priorisierung und keinerlei Beeinflussung. Die stehen alle, alle Internetpakete, die in das Kabel gelegt werden, äh stehen dann in einer Reihe und gehen da nach und nach durch.
Das ist so die die grobe äh geniale Idee des Internets und da gab es ein es gibt auch ein es gibt ein Bild vom Internet,
Es gibt ein Bild vom Internet und das werde ich jetzt mal twittern. Ja, im Moment, wenn ich das jetzt hier finde, Bild vom Internet, das ist.
Vom ganzen Internet. Ist das nicht so eine kleine schwarze Box?
Ja und Google in Zukunft. Ähm.
Es sieht ähm ja, ich twittere es. Das ist jetzt eine große Datei. Wollen wir mal gucken, ähm ob eure ProWall ob.
Das aushält. Volle Dossattacke jetzt hier auf.
Und zwar twittere ich das, muss ich nur noch hier Twitter finden.
Ja. Für unsere Podcast-Förer. Wir äh haben das natürlich in unseren eleganten Shownotes dann äh auch drin. Oder ist das jetzt irgendwie nicht jugendfrei? Ach so, okay, das ist da sozusagen schon drin.
Ja, das ist das kopiere ich grade aus den Shownotes heraus. Und das hat getwittert der Account at ME Unterstrich Netzpolitik.
Welches ist unser offizieller Twitter-Account, falls ihr dem noch nicht folgt, dann könnt ihr das Health auch mal machen.
ME Unterstrich Netzpolitik. War das, ne?
Da sieht man also äh für alle, die keinen Computer und kein da sieht man so, wie sich diese Struktur ergibt,
Also man hat hier so ein äh so ein hin und her und dann gibt's hier irgendwie so, das scheint so ein Provider zu sein, da geht dann irgendwie ein Kabel raus und das da da haben die also irgendwie mal die Ruten zwischen ein paar IP-Adressen ähm visualisiert.
So ein bisschen aus wie so ein Keller nach dreißig Jahren Kabel rein und rausschmeißen. Genau. Es ist ein so so aber schön.
So so sieht das, so sieht das Internet äh logisch aufgebaut von von innen aus. Wenn man, wenn man versucht, es zu visualisieren.
Muss ich meine Notizen wiederfinden.
So, also mit anderen Worten, was du jetzt mir äh äh mitteilen möchtest, ist, dass äh sozusagen die Internetstruktur ist schon mal nicht einheitlich, sondern da gibt's irgendwie die großen und die kleinen Fische.
Es gibt die Großen und die kleinen und es gibt eine sehr, sehr uneinheitliche Verbindung dazwischen. Und ähm.
Mhm. Und ähm im Wesentlichen hierarchisch, auch wenn's an manchen Stellen sich sozusagen äh es gibt es, es gibt sozusagen Teile, wo Kommunikation untergleichen möglich ist, aber es gibt nicht so viele die gleiche.
Genau. Wie das wie das äh im Rest der Welt auch so ist. Ja. Ähm.
Wie im richtigen Leben. Ähm da sagt noch mal einer, das Internet hätte mit der Realität nichts zu tun.
Da sage ich jetzt gar nichts. Wir gehen zum nächsten Thema. Ähm also der Provider kommt hin und sagt uns, er kriegt aber am Ende eine Rechnung für seine Bandbreite. Und wir wollen natürlich immer mehr Bandbreite.
Wollen YouTube-Videos sehen, wir wollen HD Videos sehen und so weiter
und ähm es gibt vor allem dann auch Anbieter, die da irgendwo im Internet sind, also zum Beispiel so jemand wie Google oder YouTube, die müssen sich natürlich auch Gedanken machen, wo sie Internet herkriegen. Die gehen ja nicht ähm zur äh zur Telekom und sagen hallo liebe Telekom,
wir hätten da gerne irgendwie zehn Mal VDSL
und ähm dann stecken wir da unsere Serverfarmen dran, sondern die haben natürlich ganz andere, die betreiben dann ihre eigenen Backboards und legen irgendwo ihre Kabel hin und und haben aber irgendwie alle möglichen Verträge, ist also nicht nur
nicht nur von den Routen und der Techniker ein wirres Geflecht, sondern auch von den Vereinbarungen, die Firmen untereinander haben.
Und jetzt ist es also so, dass unser Internetanbieter,
Tendenziell immer mehr Bandbreite kaufen und an uns durchgeben muss und wir aber immer das Gleiche bezahlen. Natürlich sinken die Preise dann auch mal wieder und so. Aber so ungefähr die die Situation, der der sich gegenüber sieht,
und ähm,
Wir wollen aber irgendwie keine Kilo weit äh oder Megabit äh Megabite Preise mehr, wir wollen keine Volumentarife mehr in unseren Festnetz äh Internetanschlüssen haben, sondern wir wollen Flatrates haben. Niemand macht mehr Internet nach Minuten oder nach nach Datenmenge,
daraus den Fehler ähm haben die im mobilen Bereich nicht mehr gemacht. Immobilienbereich gibt's sofort ähm Volumentarife,
Niemand hat ein freies Volumen auf einer 3G-Karte.
Warum bezeichnest du das als Fehler?
Das ist jeder ähm Unternehmensberater würde es dir als Fehler.
Ja weil ich mein de facto sind doch diese Flatrate jetzt eigentlich gar keine Flatrates. Ich meine, es gibt ja ein ein. Es gibt irgendwie ein ein Maximum. Das heißt, man hat,
schon im Prinzip einen Volumentarif, der aber nicht sozusagen jedes einzelne Bit zählt, sondern eben bis zu einem bestimmten Kontingent und dann greifen halt.
Das auf deinem Festnetz?
Na ja, theoretisch hast du das bei manchen Festnetzen sehr wohl, wenn du da einfach zu viel Daten nutzt, wobei dieses zu viel,
teilweise schwammig teilweise etwas konkreter ist. Dann ist da halt einfach limit, nur dass dieses Limit in der Regel so hoch ist, dass der normale User das eben nie sieht. Und es eben wirklich nur die exzessiven äh äh Nutzer sind, die äh an der Stelle diese äh Latte reißen.
Ich finde das auch in gewisser Hinsicht verträglich, ja? Äh weil man sich eben bis zum bestimmten Zeitpunkt keine Gedanken mehr machen muss. Die Frage ist halt bloß immer nur, was passiert, wenn man eben die Latte reißt,
fängt's an, dann teuer zu werden, was
sozusagen wieder extrem äh äh schmerzhaft ist und ja auch so ein Missbrauchs äh Potenzial birgt, also durch Dritte quasi und ähm oder dass man eben dann gar kein Internet hat oder eben langsames.
Langsames Internet.
Naja, na gut, irgendwas muss ja passieren.
Also es ist klar zu beobachten, die Mobilfunk als die irgendwann ankamen und sagten, hier Internet, die haben niemals gesagt, es gibt eine Flatrate. Die haben immer gesagt, es also ne die haben immer gesagt, es gibt eine Flatrate, sie haben nur immer dazu geschrieben, äh dass die Flatrate hält nach dreihundert MB aufhört.
Oder dann ist sie ja immer noch Flat, nur äh irgendwie halb so schnell, ja?
Ja, also die Geschichte der Flatrate ist eine Geschichte der Missverständnisse, voller Administration.
Also sagen sie, äh man kriegt im Prinzip einen Volumentarif, wo sie sagen, du hast gehört, so viele Internetnutzen wie du willst, nur ähm ab äh irgendwie ab so und so viel MB wird das Internet dann irgendwie nicht mehr nutzbar. Ähm,
Thorsten Kleins, unser Lieblings einer unserer Lieblingsjournalisten hat das für heute DE mal ausgerechnet, dass also das neue LTE Highspeed-Internet im Telekom-Netz
beworben wird mit Spitzengeschwindigkeiten von bis zu einhundert Mbit, die das Ding natürlich nie erreicht, aber äh einhundert MBit und wenn man im
Tarifmobil L ist,
und sechzig Euro im Monat an die Telekom überweist inklusive einem Gigabyte LTI Highspeed Datenvolumen,
kann man, das kann hier jeder im Publikum ausrechnen, dieses Gigabyte, was man da hat, innerhalb von achtzig Sekunden runterladen, wenn man hundert M mit bekommt.
Wenn man den Complete M hat, dann hat man dreihundert MB inklusive Volumen und braucht vierundzwanzig Sekunden.
Es gibt vierundzwanzig Sekunden Highspeed-Internet,
und danach vierundsechzig äh Kilobitt die Sekunde, das heißt, das Internet wird irgendwie um Faktor anderthalbtausend langsamer. Aber Flat, ne.
Naja, ist äh da da trifft ja das Begriff Speed auch so, ist ein bisschen wie bei den Drogen da. Das geht dann auch sehr schnell,
geht's dann schnell bergab.
Schmale Planke. Na ja und ähm jetzt ist die Frage, okay,
du sagtest gerade schon, das kann man eigentlich nachvollziehen, weil ähm ich kann das nur Volumen ja nutzen, solange wie ich will,
und wofür ich will und ähm solange mein Anbieter mir eine kompatible äh Möglichkeit bietet, meinen Bedarf an an Volumen gerecht zu werden, kann ich ja eigentlich zufrieden sein. Das heißt, ich gut, äh wenn du
Du stößt jedes Mal in deine fünf Gigabyte, ne?
Meinst mobil? Ja, die äh ich würde sagen, so in drei bis vier Monaten von den zwölf pro Jahr reichen fünf Gigabyte nicht. Das sind halt immer die, wo man viel unterwegs ist. Ja. Dann ist vorbei.
Und ähm ich zum Beispiel äh bewege mich in Bereichen, in denen es WLAN gibt und komme glaube ich regelmäßig nicht über zweihundert MB.
Ich habe aber auch ein iPhone drei G, also ich glaube, das kann auch gar nicht viel mehr als zwei.
Mensch Junge, guckst ja nicht raus, Mensch, du siehst ja die Sonne nicht. Okay.
Ähm aber das also man
kann sich dann darüber Schrott lachen und sagen, haha, äh eure Werbeversprechen sind äh lächerlich und wir haben sie enttarnt. Aber sie sind wenigstens ähm sofern nichts nichts wirklich,
das das Netz ist ja immer noch neutral, weil sowohl zu zu hundert Mbitgeschwindigkeit als auch zu,
zu einer äh sehr viel geringeren vierundsechzig Kilo Bittgeschwindigkeit kommen die Pakete da in einer Reihe an und keins wird bevorteiligt oder benachteiligt. Ähm insofern ist das ein ein fairer Deal, ähm den sie uns da anbieten.
Der sich eben auch naja durch die ökonomischen Zwänge, den ja so ein Konzern unterworfen ist, äh der ja auch seine Subsistenz sichern muss,
auch rechtfertigen lässt. Die Frage ist, wann ist jetzt so ein Netz nicht mehr neutral?
Und ähm wenn man sich jetzt das mal historisch anschaut, diese dieser Internetzugang wird uns ja gegeben von von Firmen, die bevor sie irgendwann auf,
kam den Leuten Internet äh zu geben über die Kupferkabel, die sie in ihre Wohnung gelegt hatten.
Haben die äh Telefonie angeboten. Und die waren an so Preismodelle ähm gewöhnt, wie dass man für eine weitere Strecke den Leuten mehr Geld abnimmt.
Ja? Äh Ferngesprächzone eins, zwei, drei oder was und äh Ausland, hier, Ausland, da und nach achtzehn Uhr kostet mehr oder weniger und äh wenn du,
ne und solche Modelle, ja, die waren also immer daran gewöhnt, dass man irgendwie vielleicht noch einen Sonderdienst, eine Nullhundertneunziger-Nummer anbietet und
nullhundertneunziger Dienst ergibt, kriegt er anrufende Zeit drei Euro sechzig und der Angerufene bekommt zwei Euro vierzig und die Telekom bekommt einen Euro zwanzig und solche solche schönen Modelle oder auch null achthunderter Nummern,
Service, ja kannst du umsonst anrufen. Ähm
und derjenige, der umsonst angerufen wird, muss halt ein paar tausend Euro im Monat an die Telekom zahlen. Solche Modelle waren die, waren die gewöhnt und das haben die jahrzehntelang so gemacht und das fanden die auch ganz toll. Und jetzt haben sie auf einmal,
da dieses Internet, was die Leute haben, die machen da nicht nur können sie damit in in die ganze Welt internetten, sondern sie fangen dann auf einmal auch noch an äh darüber Skype zu machen,
und ähm in dem Fall dann das konkrete Geschäftsmodell des äh Anbieters anzugreifen, der und da kommen wir jetzt wieder zu dem Mobiltelefon, da haben sie ja die ganzen Fehler nicht gemacht. Da gab's ja von vorne rein die Voice-Over-IP-Sperre,
Vielleicht gab's irgendwie ganz, ganz früher mal keine, aber.
Schon sehr verbreitet, ja.
So, das heißt äh im im dem äh dem Vertrag steht drin, hallo, du hast Internet von uns, Internetflatrate außer Voice of IP Skype und äh sonstige Sachen,
ähm das darfst du erstmal nicht nutzen. Ähm,
Die nächste, die naheliegende Konsequenz ist natürlich, das irgendwie zu sperren oder irgendwie zu unterbinden. Ähm,
ein bisschen zu wie einfach oder wie schwierig das tatsächlich ist. Aber auf Mobiltelefone
habe ich also nicht nur haben sie nicht nur gelernt, okay, wir müssen ihnen irgendwann das Volumen beschränken, sondern sie haben auch gelernt, äh wir müssen aufpassen, dass die auch weiterhin schön ihre hundert Inklusivminuten bezahlen wollen.
Ansonsten möchten die Leute nämlich nur noch Daten, SIM-Karten haben in ihren äh in ihren iPhones und nicht mehr äh nicht mehr die schönen Telefonpakete oder,
bewahre, die fangen auf einmal an, SMS übers Internet zu schicken und zahlen uns nicht mehr zwanzig Cent für die äh für die paar Biots.
Ja, ja. Die teuersten Bits der Welt.
Und natürlich, was in der Tat wirklich negativ problematisch wäre für äh für,
UMTS und GSM-Netze, wenn die Leute jetzt anfangen würden mit suppierte Diensten, die oder so. Das wäre also tatsächlich eine Herausforderung für für diese Netze, weil,
sie einen etwas anderen Aufbau haben oder ein etwas andere Problem ausgesetzt sind als äh Kabelnetze,
Kabel, da kann ich einfach immer nochmal ein Kabel nebenlegen und dann habe ich die doppelte Bandbreite oder ich habe ein besseres Kabel, dann wird die Bandbreite sogar mehr als verdoppelt, dadurch, dass ein Kabel daneben lege,
Ähm ich habe ja schon mal in der Sendung gesagt, die Luft ist irgendwann voll,
Raum von Frequenzen, auf den ich mit Mobiltelefonen funken darf. Und ähm irgendwann,
auf dem Band, was ich bezahlt habe, wofür ich Lizenzen gekauft habe, einfach keinen Platz mehr. Kann jeder bei sich zu Hause beobachten, ähm der in der Großstadt wohnt,
gegen zwanzig Uhr ist das Internet sehr langsam, es liegt wahrscheinlich nicht daran, dass das Internet tatsächlich langsam wird, sondern dass eure WLANs durch die zwanzigtausend anderen WLANs, die auch auf den,
Dreizehn Kanälen, wovon vier ohne Interferenzen betrieben werden können. Funken sich gegenseitig stören.
Ähm das heißt, da haben sie noch ein bisschen bisschen andere Probleme und sind eigentlich daran interessiert, dass da wirklich nicht so viel genutzt wird.
Ein Drama.
Ein Drama. Ähm aber äh zurück zu unserem, zu unserem Provider, ähm wenn der die Sachen dann, was irgendwann mal bei an ihm durchgekrochen ist und ins oder den Transit gegeben wird, das fließt dann da auch durch. Und ähm.
Das heißt, ich möchte als Provider, muss ich hingehen und irgendwie vor meine Internetdose, wo ich dann äh wo die wo die Leute alle rein wollen, muss ich dann irgendwie ein bisschen gucken und sagen, das darfst du, das darfst du nicht.
Ich fange dann an zu äh zum Beispiel, was sehr, sehr elegant ist. Vielleicht sperre ich's auch nicht ganz. Also ähm ATNT hatte, glaube ich, diese Verabredung mit Apple,
oder mit Skype, dass denen gesagt wurde, dass Äpfel gesagt wurde, passt auf, ihr lasst die Skype App nur in euren App Store,
wenn die Skype App nur dann Telefonie macht, wenn sie das übern WLAN macht und nicht über über das äh über das Zellnetzwerk,
Dann wurde die äh würde die App erstmal so verkauft. Dann kamen die J-Breaker und haben gesagt, okay, wir schreiben die iPhone Software so um, dass die Skype-Software denkt, sie wäre im WLAN,
dann funktioniert's auch über über das ATNT-Netz und dann hat ATNT gesagt, okay äh äh dann machen wir jetzt mal irgendwie hier so eine äh eine Sperre für Skype und dann haben sie gemerkt, oh Skype sperren ist schwierig,
Skype, da kann man nicht braucht man kann man nicht einfach eine IP oder so sperren, weil es sind Direktverbindungen, also mussten sie irgendwie anfangen, den Traffic zu analysieren und zu gucken, was was sieht da nach Skype aus und wie können wir das irgendwie
verhindern. Und dann sind sie auch auf die Idee gekommen, pass auf, wir verhindern das gar nicht, sondern wir bremsen das einfach so aus, dass die Leute sich nicht mehr vernünftig hören und das ruckelt.
Und dann bieten wir den Leuten an, hat die Telekom jetzt auch so.
Wer hat das gemacht?
Das ist jetzt eine bösartige Unterstellung.
Ach so, das.
Also ich meine, du kannst dir angucken, wie viel Daten Skype braucht, das äh ist nicht annähernd irgendwie äh gefährdet äh irgendeine Latte zu reißen, bei bei einer UMTS-Verbindung,
Konferenz drüber führen, wenn du möchtest. Wenn du das durch den VPN Tunnels, dann funktioniert das sogar. Wenn das nicht durch einen VPN Tunnel ist, dann funktioniert's leider nicht.
Aber da kommt die Telekom ja und sagt, ja, guck mal, lieber Tim, wenn du, also du bist ja kein Tierkongress, aber hier jemand anders. Ach, hör mal, ach so, du wolltest Skype benutzen, ja, gar kein Problem,
zahlst du einfach einen Zehner mehr.
Okay. Ja.
Okay. Kannst du Skype benutzen, sonst eben nicht. Ähm ist ein Zusatzdienst übrigens, den wir dir jetzt äh exklusiv anbieten können und ähm.
Ist das derzeit eigentlich immer noch so? Ja, ne?
Also steht in, steht in jedem Vertrag so noch drin.
Ja. Ich habe mir jetzt die Tarife.
Ich versuche jetzt, muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich äh bin es auch leid, das auszuprobieren. Vielleicht äh machen sie's inzwischen gar nicht mehr, weil weil sie wissen, dass es keiner mehr versucht.
Ich gucke mal. Ich meine, das Schwierigste an diesen Tarifen ist ja, sie überhaupt erstmal zu begreifen, weil wenn man sich das so durchliest, also keine Ahnung,
Das ist so ein bisschen wie äh ein Abend am Kaminfeuer mit einem Juristen.
Offiziell begründet Skype das äh begründet die Telekom oder jeder andere Provider das dann damit, dass äh dass er das Internet verstopft für die anderen.
Und ähm deswegen ähm müssen wir irgendwie dahin zurück, dass die Leute dafür bezahlen, wenn sie besonders Bandbreiten intensiv arbeiten, aber Skype ist wirklich nicht besonders Bandbreiten intensiv.
Aber es stimmt, ne? Es ist immer noch in den Tarifen drin, also zumindest jetzt, wenn ich mal hier den fettesten äh anklicke, der dann gleich so mit hundert Euro äh zu Buchen schlägt, dann ist dann sozusagen auch Internettelefonie mit drin.
Aha, in dem ist es dann drin. Die kostet hundert Euro.
Ja ja und auch SMS-Flatrate in alle Netze sozusagen. Wenn du hundert Euro zahlst, dann wollen sie ja auch jetzt äh nicht mehr das goldene Bit verkaufen.
Übrigens, wo du gerade sagst, SMS, es gibt ja diesen äh Dienst, WhatsApp, der sich sehr äh hoher Beliebtheit erfreut. Ähm das war ja ganz spannend. Da hatten die irgendwie nicht mit gerechnet, dass äh ihnen das irgendwie so eine iPhone App dahergeht. Ähm die
ihn auf einmal die die SMS kaputt macht oder die SMS nicht so wirklich aber die MMS,
Ne und ähm sie waren auch glaube ich ein bisschen überrascht, als Apple dann irgendwann sagte, ach übrigens, wir machen jetzt ein Message und das schieben wir auch durch das Internet durch. Ähm,
Das heißt, sie haben sich dann an anderen Stellen auch wirklich wurden sie auf dem kalten Fuß erwischt, weil sie
offensichtlich die Juristen vergessen hatten, irgendwie in den ähm in den äh kleinen Text da unten reinzuschreiben, äh E-Mails dürfen sie aber nicht äh Kurznachrichten, die nicht über E-Mail ausgetauscht werden, ja? Ähm,
Das heißt, über über sowas wie WhatsApp ärgern die sich sicherlich auch sehr,
Nicht mehr schnell genug geschafft, dass diese Entwicklung zu erkennen und dass das wirklich zu unterbinden. Aber natürlich untergräbt das unglaublich ihr Geschäftsmodell,
sicherlich freuen, dass jetzt äh WhatsApp sich entpuppt hat, also ungefähr der sicherheitsrelevante, sicherheitstechnisch gesehene größte Haufen misst, den jemals irgendjemand in eine App geschrieben hat,
sodass jetzt keiner mehr WhatsApp benutzen möchte. Aber ähm.
Naja, also die Nerds nicht, aber äh ich glaube, die meisten Leute benutzen das einfach genauso. Bisher ist jetzt nicht gerade so die breaking News, die äh es auf die Seite eins der Bild-Zeitung schafft, oder doch?
Als Spiegel Online drüber berichtet, dass bei Computersicherheitsthemen echt.
Wie Bild jetzt für dich.
Das ist noch das das Gleiche für Bild, ja.
Na ja, na gut.
Okay, gut.
So, aber das Spannende an diesem Paket mit dem mit Skype ist, dass sie sagen, ähm ihr dürft Skype nicht benutzen, weil es Bandbreiten intensiv ist und das stimmt schon mal nicht, ja? Und dann sagen sie, das Problem lässt sich aber mit Geld lösen.
Ja. Naja, weil wenn du mehr Geld zahlst, dann äh erweitert sich ja auch der Frequenzraum auf einmal. Genau. Also ist dein Telefon,
so eine Art Raumverzerrung durch, ja, das ist äh haben wir alles, Albert Einstein äh zu verdanken, dass du dann so durch so ein spezielles äh Protokoll den Raum krümmst und dann passt da einfach auch noch Wolken mit durch.
Also quasi die Gravitation des Zehn-Euro-Scheines, der mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit zur Telekom.
Genau. So in die, so ähnlich hat mir das mal jemand auf, ja so also so ähnlich klang das, als mir das mal jemand auf einer Messe erklärt hat.
Ah ja, ja, ja, ja, nee, dann okay. So, wir sehen also, sie äh sie haben hier.
Wobei äh solche Messerhallen, die es einem sowieso den Raum krümmen, weil danach,
man eh nicht mehr wo oben und unten ist.
So, also sie sagen ja sich irgendwie an der an der Preisgestaltung und sagen, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie mal anfangen zu priorisieren.
Und das ist natürlich, das ist jetzt der der Punkt, also hier, hier holpert jetzt auch ein bisschen der Übergang, sehe ich grade in meinen Notizen,
Ja, mal gucken. Ich, also wir kommen jetzt langsam dazu, dass sie, dass sie sagen, wir wollen euch dann außerdem noch anbieten, dass bestimmte Dinge schneller gehen. Was so ein, so ein besonders schönes äh Beispiel ist, ist immer ähm,
die Fern-OP. Ihr kennt das, man kommt ins Krankenhaus,
und der Herzspezialist aus Neu Delhi macht Paket vermittelt, eine Fern-OP mit so einem Roboter,
passiert jeden Tag. So und.
Drei G.
Über drei K,
mit seinem iPad macht er die.
Ja.
Das ist natürlich dann wichtige Daten, das heißt, da ist ein, da ist ein IP-Paket, was da ins Internet reinkommt, durch das äh Kabel und sagt, hallo, ich muss nach äh Berlin, da liegt der Linus, der verblutet grade. Und ähm,
und dann, so jetzt die Geschichte, ich, jetzt gebe das nur so weiter, das erzählt hier jeder Messer, Heini. Ähm und dann kommt aber jetzt eine E-Mail vom Tim,
Er ist auch gerade in Neu-Delhi. Ähm kommt jetzt und die drängelt sich aber vor. Und der ist jetzt total blöd, wenn,
Ich verblute, weil du eine E-Mail geschickt hast. Ne? Und deswegen.
Schwein. Ich sau.
Ne. So und deswegen muss ähm muss priorisiert werden.
Verstehe. Deswegen.
So, das heißt, dieses Daten, dieses Datenpaket muss irgendwie einen Stempel dran kriegen, wichtiges Datenpaket, einige Blutkonserve oder so. Und wandert dann schneller durchs Internet. Und überall durch die ganzen Switches, durch die das so fliegt,
oh ey komm mal vorbei, komm mal vorbei, komm vorbei, bist wichtiger als die anderen. Ähm das Problem ist erstens,
Arzt ernsthaft seine OP über dieses Netzwerk Internet schieben möchte und sich nicht irgendwie eine eigene Leitung organisiert mit einer garantierten Bandbreite,
Aber das Problem ist auch, dass diese Priorisiererei im Moment nicht so gut funktioniert, dass jeder es mitmachen würde,
Weg zwischen Neu Deli und mir,
das ja durch ganz viele Knoten geht und das sind immer wieder Kabel, wo irgendwelche Leute mal irgendwie einen Vertrag hatten, wie sie mit diesem äh Traffic umgehen wollen. Das heißt, diese spannende Geschichte, dass ein Paket ernsthaft den den Stempel kriegt
ich bin wichtiger und dann vom ganzen Internet auch so behandelt wird. Die funktioniert nicht. Und selbst wenn es so wäre.
Müsste man sich in diesem wunderbaren äh Kuddelmuddel überlegen, was bekommt denn der Switch X in der Mitte zwischen Neu Deli und Berlin dafür, dass er jetzt meine Daten priorisiert? Der will ja irgendwas dafür haben,
sonst würde er es ja nicht tun. Das heißt, wir hätten wirklich auf jedem Kabel im Internet irgendwie so eine Art Wegzoll, dass man sagt, bei uns kostet übrigens priorisiertes Paket, äh kostet Aufschlag so und so. Das heißt, es ist,
Nicht nur funktioniert nur, nicht nur technisch gerade nicht, sondern es würde auch ein ungelöstes Problem darstellen, wenn es funktionieren würde. Zweite Problem.
Noch nicht mal nachweisen kann, dass irgendwas wirklich priorisiert weitergeleitet wurde.
Richtig. Man man kann ja immer sagen, wurde, also ich würde dann so.
Ja ja, ich habe das total schnell, total. Ja.
Hier ist gerade die Hölle los, da hier äh ganzen Nierentransplantation und so.
Ja, sie sind alle nur am Operieren eigentlich die ganze Zeit, ja. Das ganze Internet. Das ist jetzt irgendwie nach WhatsApp, ja, sind sie alle enttäuscht, zur Fernoperation äh übergegangen,
Die Doktorspielchen der Kinder spielt sich halt heute äh mit dem iPad ab. So, das.
Und dann kommt natürlich das nächste Problem, was hindert mich daran, das mit all meinen Daten zu tun? Einfach zu sagen, jedes Paket von mir hier, immer schön Priorität ziehen, ja? Das heißt,
was da erzählt wird, ist einfach unrealistisch, was denen, was sie wirkliche Funktion des Internets angeht. Zumindest, wenn ich behaupten möchte, ähm dass ich so etwas, dass ich eine Priorisierung zusichern kann.
Also als Dienst, den ich anbieten kann. Und da muss man genau unterscheiden, weil was sie sehr wohl machen ist, erkennen,
ob eine Anwendung grade zeitkritisch ist oder nicht,
und das wird an an vielen verschiedenen Punkten gemacht, dass man also schaut, okay, ein äh bestimmter Traffic sollte hier bevorzugt werden. Das macht zum Beispiel,
jede Fritzbox. Schon in der Fritzfox gibt's einen QS Quality of Service und die äh ist
standardmäßig so eingestellt, dass eine ähm ein Videotelefon oder ein eine äh Internettelefonie auf jeden Fall zeitkritisch bevorzugt behandelt wird. Äh im Vergleich zu jedem anderen Dienst.
Weil ich,
Egal, was ich mache, ich möchte nicht. Wenn ich dann grade, wenn mir gerade übers Internettelefon jemand gesagt hat, was ich runterladen soll, dass dieser Download die Verbindung abbrechen lässt,
Das ist allerdings Bandbreitenmanagement, das heißt, da wird dann geschaut, okay, wie kann ich dem Dienst angemessen agieren,
oder also man sieht, okay, das ist jetzt wirklich, das scheint eins, das ist wirklich ein zeitkritisches Paket und deswegen behandle ich es auch so. Und das mache ich deshalb, damit meine Nutzer zufrieden sind.
Ja oder auch um äh das Problem dieser asymmetrischen DSL-Leitung ein bisschen äh zu verbessern. Äh wird ja auch schon längere Zeit des äh denke ich doch ist das noch so, ne, äh dass diese,
Pakete vom dann sozusagen auch bevorzugt äh rüber geschickt werden, damit's halt nicht sich alles staut.
Die genauen Regeln kenne ich nicht, aber das ist sehr gut möglich, ja. Wer würde auf jeden Fall Sinn machen? Ähm ärgerlich wird das natürlich dann, wenn ich sage, ach, weißt du was, das mache ich aber jetzt nur noch bei bestimmten Diensten,
Das heißt, ich mache eine Regel in meinen Switch rein, der sagt,
Wenn das ein YouTube-Video ist, dann schieben wir das mal schnell vorne dran vorbei,
Wenn das ein Vimeo Video ist, dann kann sich das ja zu den E-Mails stellen in die Schlange.
Und da bietet sich natürlich, da bieten sich wunderbare äh Möglichkeiten, Geld zu verdienen, weil der Provider kann an der Stelle sagen, ähm,
Ich komme jetzt ins ich komme so zum Internet und sage hallo liebes Internet. Ähm ich habe hier einen Dienst.
Und dann könnte natürlich mein Provider kommen und sagen oder könnte ein Provider kommen, die Telekom sagt dann, schönen Dienst haben sie da. Wäre doch schade, wenn der ruckelt.
So ein bisschen Schutzgebühr, ne, irgendwie so. Mein so.
Das wäre natürlich total toll für.
Schöner, ja, schöner Laden hier, hübsches Porzellan und so, ist wäre ja total schade, wenn das irgendwie kaputt gehen würde oder so. Ja, ist.
Das wäre echt schade, ne. Und der Blöde ist, das kann nicht nur die Telekom machen, sondern das kann jeder Scheißprovider auf dem Planeten der Erde machen, weil ihr alle nur dieses letzte Stück eigentlich unter ihrer wirklichen Kontrolle haben. Und zwar das das Stück zum Nutzer.
Also es würde, ja, gut, äh ich glaube nicht, dass alle Provider das jetzt ohne Weiteres tun können, weil es gibt ja auch reine äh äh reine Verbinder, sozusagen reine äh äh Netzverbinder und ich glaube, da würden dann die jeweiligen Netze schon so ein bisschen sich dann auch mal andere äh,
Suchen.
Das hat Google ein Teilen der Welt gemacht. Die haben teilweise wirklich ihre eigene Kabel liegen.
Ja, ich meine, Google ist ein weltweiter äh Netzanbieter und die haben ihre eigenen Netze genau deswegen, damit sie eben auch nicht
da groß gefickt werden von den anderen Providern, sondern dass sie einfach das garantieren können. Also hat natürlich noch viele andere Gründe auch, dass sie ihren Content quasi,
soweit schon mal in Richtung des Kunden bringen, dass er gar nicht erst so weite Wege gehen muss, um diese Bandbreitenproblematik generell schon mal in den Griff zu bekommen, aber es hilft ihnen natürlich auch, an der Stelle äh äh nicht zu erpressbar zu werden.
Und insofern ist es sowieso ein bisschen albern, weil die Anbieter, die jetzt wirklich die ganze Zeit an die Wand gestellt werden, dass sie jetzt hier besonders viel Daten,
ins Netz einspeisen. Die,
in dieses Netz ein, die haben große Netze und äh tun schon ihren Teil. Also es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass YouTube da äh die ganzen Daten auf so einem,
vier sechsundachtziger äh äh irgendwo in ein Mountainview fährt, so ja, wo dann so fünf Glasfaserkabel angeschlossen werden und dann müssen die anderen da mal äh bluten, sondern
Das ist schon auch teuer.
Selbstverständlich ist das teuer. Also ohne Frage kostet das hier Geld. Ich möchte nur oder ich will so ein bisschen zeigen, was da vielleicht der Anreiz für die Provider ist. Ähm da mal über das, was es tatsächlich kostet, bis hinaus zu gehen.
Ja klar, ne, deswegen fiel mir das gleich so dieses Bild mit diesem Schutzgelderpressung äh ein, ne, weil das so ein bisschen eigentlich ohne Not ist,
Man fängt halt sozusagen mit einem erstmal an, so den hat man dann schon mal so bevorteilt und so, ach ihr wollt auch äh also ihr wollt jetzt sozusagen nicht benachteiligt werden, wo wir jetzt schon mal den einen schon mal rausgepickt haben zu bevorteilen, äh dann tja, könnt ihr ja auch zahlen.
Wird sozusagen jedes Bit nochmal extra vernickelt und vergoldet. Ja. Hm.
Und das genau der dieser schöne Punkt, das ist ähm wenn man irgendwo von Priorisierung spricht
dann spricht man gleichzeitig von Diskriminierung. Das heißt, wenn ich irgendwas priorisiere, wird das andere äh zurückgestellt.
Und ähm das Entscheidende sind natürlich die Kriterien, die ich an der Stelle ansetze, wenn das äh Kriterien sind, die sich nur auf den Port beziehen ähm oder auf den
Header des IP-Paketes, wie es so bei äh Stateful Inspection ist, also
nur anhand des Headers im IP-Paket, da stehen dann so Sachen drin, ich gehe von da nach da und ich bin äh ich möchte da bitte auf Fort achtzig und ich bin.
Was meinst du mit? Kannst du das mal.
Dass es im Gegensatz zu Depacket Inspection,
also da werden die äh Behandlungsregeln nur darauf gerichtet, was im IP Header steht. Das heißt, der Switch guckt in den oder der der Router guckt in den Header rein,
behandelt dementsprechend ähm besser oder schlechter oder äh priorisiert. Das zum Beispiel bei ähm.
Warum heißt das nicht äh Inspection? Ich meine, was ist da der State, der da irgendwie.
Ich weiß es, sie ist heiß so. Ähm es heißt so. Äh das also das so diese ganzen Q US-Sachen, die funktionieren darauf basierend. Ähm,
und dem von dem abzugrenzen ist also die wo dann nicht nur der angeguckt wird, sondern auch der Datenteil. Das brauche ich zum Beispiel, wenn ich ähm,
Skype erkennen möchte, weil Skype sich sehr viel Mühe gibt, äh nicht als solches aufzufallen. Das heißt, ein einzelnes Paket kann ich mir nicht anschauen und mit hoher mit mit sicherer Wahrscheinlichkeit sagen, dass es jetzt Skype,
Da haben äh die Provider immer wieder Probleme mit äh wirklich Skype zu unterbinden.
Ähm ein Paket ist, was noch durch einen VPN äh läuft oder so, dann habe ich natürlich noch größere Schwierigkeiten.
Ja oder bitterer, nicht wahr? Also.
Ähm.
Verschlüsselung, die da gemacht wird, wird ja im Prinzip auch nur zur Verschleierung gefahren.
Genau und äh da habe ich also dann größere Schwierigkeiten. Also ich kann nicht eine einfache Regel schreiben, so wie äh IP Tablets Blog Betont. Das äh geht so so leicht nicht. Da brauche ich also äh muss ich den Traffic mir genauer anschauen,
und sagen, okay ähm dieser äh,
Dieses Paket scheint zu diesem und jenem Dienst oder Anbieter oder so zu gehören und das äh ist bei uns unerwünscht und deswegen äh bremsen wir jetzt mal diesen Portbereich oder diesen diese Rute oder so ein bisschen aus,
ähm das heißt ähm ich müsste
oder ich muss dazu eine vollautomatisierte äh Vollüberwachung machen. Ich muss hier also gesamten Traffic anschauen
dazu geeigneten Geräten, das wird nicht mehr mit Hilfe von CPUs gemacht, sondern wirklich in also sehr viel schnelleren Teilen, also irgendwelchen FPGAs oder so, dass man live den Traffic sich anschaut
und versucht da irgendwie möglichst zu sortieren und zu erkennen, was ist da etwas, was ich nicht haben möchte
und dank habe ich die Möglichkeit Skype zu unterbinden mit diesen Geräten.
Dass die Inspektion wird auch noch für andere Sachen benutzt, die jetzt aber nicht unbedingt zum Thema gehören, aber sowas wie ähm.
Loveul Interception, also die Polizei fragt beim Provider an, gib uns doch mal den Traffic von Tim, der äh kommt uns irgendwie nicht ganz
geheuer vor. Wir müssen mal gucken, was der im Internet so macht. Der ist da irgendwie immer und ähm dann kann man das also auch mit DPI äh mit solchen schnellen Geräten also machen.
Ähm ist also ist schlecht. Ähm,
Man sollte aber diesen diesen Überwachungsbegriff jetzt nicht allzu dramatisch nehmen, weil die Datenmengen, die da durchlaufen, wirklich äh enormstens sind. Enormstend,
sind. Äh das heißt, diese Dinger speichern jetzt nicht so wirklich, aber es äh es wird wirklich, dass jedes einzelne Datenpaket
heuristisch angeschaut und entsprechend dann der der Traffic anders behandelt. Und damit kann ich eben so schöne Sachen machen wie
Einmal den Internet irgendwelchen random Anbietern im Internet, als auch meinen Nutzern äh gegenüber die Hand aufzuhalten. Und im Moment ist es so, dass die
Deutschen Provider, insbesondere die äh Deutsche Telekom, aber auch alle anderen, in dieser Richtung ähm sehr stark sich bemühen ähm
nicht äh eine gesetzliche Regelung zu bekommen, die ihnen das verbietet. Sondern sie wollen sich diese Modelle offen halten. Ähm.
Und wir reden.
You Bastards.
Ja, so wenn man sich das also jetzt, man muss da ehrlich zu sagen, das ist ähm dann also wenn man das macht.
Dann macht man damit wirklich den den Kern dessen kaputt, was das Internet ist,
nämlich ein äh Netz nach dem Best-Effer-Prinzip, wo jede wo jeder irgendwie ähm seine Daten reinwerfen kann, sie kommen am anderen Ende raus. Ähm,
es ist äh wie würde man das sagen? Also es ist es wird, es ist technisch in der Form nicht notwendig und in keiner Form notwendig,
und ähm ist also deswegen ganz ganz bäh. Aber,
ähm der Provider hat also jeden finanziellen Anreiz, ähm das genauso
zu tun. Und deswegen tun sie das auch. Also wir haben ja diese Skype Scar Skypesperre schon behandelt. Ähm Kabel Deutschland äh hatten wir gerade erwähnt, die Drosseln, also bei Fightsharing
wenn der Nutzer zu viel Fall betreibt, also zu viele zu viel über das Bithorn-Protokoll mit anderen spricht, dann ähm
werden diese Nutzer ausgebremst.
Und ähm wir haben bis jetzt ja irgendwie die Geschichte der Netzneutralität war immer eine Geschichte dessen, dass uns etwas weggenommen wurde,
Es wurde wir man hat uns Skype weggenommen oder man hat uns weggenommen oder man hat uns da irgendwie beschränkt. Ähm sodass es immer ein bisschen, also relativ okay war, dagegen zu mobilisieren,
Also es waren Leute, die sagten, okay, da haben wir keinen Bock drauf. Wir wollen auch Skype, wir haben Internet bezahlt, wir wollen echtes Internet bekommen.
Und es war irgendwie in Deutschland, wurde dann nach und nach klar, dass man Netzneutralitätsverletzungen auf Dauer nicht wirklich etabliert bekommt, als Einschränkungen.
Ähm und deswegen wird jetzt so ein neuer Weg gefahren, den finde ich echt ähm sehr äh elegant,
Dass man sagt, hey, ihr könnt doch mal ähm wir wir verkaufen den Leuten das einfach mal als ähm als Zusatzdienstleistung und vorne herein,
und ähm der Hintergrund dessen ist, warum das jetzt so gemacht wird, ist, dass von Seiten der FDP und von Seiten der CDU,
Die Argumentation zur Frage der Netzneutralität immer war,
ja Netzneutralität klar ist total wichtig das Internet muss unbedingt Netz neutral bleiben aber wie es schon sagt eine Einschränkung der Netzneutralität liebe,
Internetkämpfer
wäre ja sowas von krass und unverschämt, da können wir uns ja total auf den Markt verlassen, weil wenn ein nicht neutralen Internetanschluss den bucht doch keiner
Insofern ist das doch eine Sache, da müssen wir doch nicht regulieren. Da laufen wir nur Gefahr über zu regulieren. Da können wir uns doch echt auf den Markt verlassen,
sowas sowas kauft dir einfach keiner, das heißt da wird der Kapitalismus wie so häufig zum Wohle aller wirken.
Wenn das schon bei den Banken so gut funktioniert.
Und ähm jetzt kam also vor ein paar Wochen an die Telekom und sagte, ey Leute, super Angebot hier für euch. Ähm bei Telekom übrigens, wenn ihr über die Telekom Spotify bucht,
dann kriegt ihr ähm zusätzlich zu eurem Inklusiv Volumen, was ihr habt in eurem Tarif,
unlimited Spotify. Das heißt, der Spotify wird nicht auf euer Datenvolumen angerechnet. Hm,
Könnte man jetzt sagen, das ist echt spitze, weil ein normaler Spotify-Account kostet auch nur einen Zehner.
Und ähm das heißt, im wenn ich den jetzt bei wenn ich einen Spotify-Account habe und ich bin bei E plus, dann wird das auf mein Datenvolumen angerechnet, äh bei Vodafone wird's auf mein Datenvolumen angerechnet und bei der bei der Telekom eben nicht.
Problem ist aber, wenn ich einen Account habe, dann wird es bei der Telekom auf meinen äh Datenvolumen angerechnet. Das heißt, ich habe jetzt einen sehr starken Anreiz,
Eher zu Spotify zu gehen als zur Telekom,
Und das nur, weil die Telekom ähm sich entschieden hat aufgrund verschiedener äh äh ökonomischer Erwägungen, ähm dass zehn Euro im Monat für diesen Dienst äh für sie in Ordnung in Ordnung gehen.
Wenn Sie das jetzt demnächst noch mit anderen Diensten machen und wir wurden in den Kommentaren darauf hingewiesen, dass zum Beispiel E Plus so ein so eine Lösung hat mit äh Facebook. Kann man bei E plus äh wenn ich da
also kein Datentarif, dann würden sie mich eigentlich pro Kilo weit äh abrechnen
Das ist ein Tarif, der ist absolut unattraktiv. Es sei denn, ich gehe auf null Punkt Facebook dot com, da kann ich kostenlos hingehen.
Ist also ein Eingriff, der äh durch nichts gerechtfertigt ist, was was irgendwo eine äh Entsprechung in der, in der Struktur des Internets hat,
und deswegen glaube ich, dass äh wir in Zukunft ähm uns nur dagegen wehren können, indem wir das äh wie Chile die USA und die Niederlande gemacht haben,
Nämlich indem wir ähm Gesetze schaffen, die das einfach verbieten.
Was hat denn äh was hat denn Chile gemacht?
Hättest du jetzt echt nicht nach USA oder Niederlande fragen können?
Na ja, ich finde das immer gerade besonders interessant, wenn es irgendwie äh so Non-Man-Stream äh äh Staaten sind, die irgendwie,
da äh unterwegs sind. Ich meine Chile, ne? Redet man ja jetzt nicht jeden Tag drüber.
Ich kann halt das äh ich kann das halt nicht so gut lesen. Chilenisch.
Chilenisch heißt Spanisch.
Weiß, kann ich trotzdem nicht.
Na lesen kann ich das. Wisst ihr nicht erklären muss.
Naja, egal.
Also du meinst, in Chile gibt's zumindest ein Netzneutralitätsgesetz. Ähm vielleicht nochmal bevor wir äh äh da weiter reingehen, was mich immer so ein bisschen verwirrt ist oder ich glaube, was auch alle ein wenig verwirrt ist, dass Netzneutralität ist ja auch mal echt mal wieder so ein Wort,
Wo ich mir nicht so sicher bin, ob in der politischen Diskussion es eigentlich gelingt, da eine allgemeine Definition für zu finden.
Ja, das das gelingt seit Jahren nicht so wirklich, weil nämlich ähm tatsächlich sich Provider melden. Die sagen,
Moment mal, euch ist schon klar, dass wir eine radikale Definition von Netzneutralität, die gerade die gesamte Zeit äh verletzen,
indem wir äh Quality of Service und Traffic Management machen. Das machen wir die ganze Zeit, sonst würde dieses Internet auch nicht mehr in nicht in dem Rahmen so gut funktionieren,
ihr das gewohnt seid. Das heißt, wenn,
Wenn man jetzt einfach wirklich sagt so, ey, das Paket muss gleich behandelt werden und jeder kommt in den Knast, der ein Paket Unrecht tut, dann ähm dann kommen selbst die Admins aus dem Keller und sagen, Moment.
Moment. So war das nicht gemacht.
Aber ähm wenn man also jetzt wirklich sich mal also auf der wirklich nur auf dieser,
Endmeile zwischen dem Endprovider und dem dem Nutzer darüber nachdenkt, dann ist es eigentlich eine relativ klare ähm,
ökonomische oder ähnliche soziale Erwägung und nicht eine äh eine technische mehr, weil ähm,
Also der Einstieg ist äh es werden einfach auch Markteinstiegsführen äh platziert. Es gibt einfach ein Kräfteverhältnis zwischen also ich meine, wenn wenn die Telekom hingeht zu YouTube und sagt, hör mal, ihr wollt doch sicherlich nicht, dass das ruckelt, dann sagt YouTube, mach doch!
Können wir ja mal gucken, was dann passiert, ja?
Na ja. Das ist ja, ich meine, die Situation gibt es ja in Deutschland. Telekom hat äh eine,
Bearbeitungswürdige Anbindung an Google und äh das performt halt nicht unbedingt immer optimal,
Es liegt einfach daran, dass sie da die entsprechenden Kapazitäten nicht haben. Wer da jetzt gerade nicht bereit ist, da äh extra Leitungen zu legen oder inwiefern das ein tatsächliches technisches Problem ist, was noch äh eine Lösung hat, das kann ich nicht äh sagen.
Aber im Prinzip äh existiert halt genau diese Situation teilweise schon, dass man eben, damit es nicht ruckelt, da auch äh,
nachlegen müsste, weil alle Kunden wollen das, ja? Jeder Kunde der Telekom kann man davon ausgehen, wird schon mal irgendein YouTube Video angeschaut haben
tut es regelmäßig, dementsprechend ist es ja auch dann die Aufgabe äh dieses Providers für die entsprechenden Zuleitungen zu sorgen. Und wenn die dann halt nicht da sind, dann ruckelt's eben auch.
Jetzt die Frage, wer wer zahlt, ne?
YouTube hat jetzt sicherlich keinen besonderen Anreiz dazu investieren, dass dass ihre Videos nicht bei der Telekom äh ruckeln,
Nehmen wir aber zum Beispiel 'n schwächeren Anbieter, 'n schwachen Konkurrenten von YouTube, also Vimeo ist in keiner Form so groß wie die. Da könnte die Telekom natürlich hingehen und sagen, hör mal Jungs, wir müssen euch da mal ein bisschen bremsen, es sei denn,
ne. Habe hier mal eine kleine Rechnung für euch. Dann geht das natürlich. Dann können wir uns da anstrengen. Also ähm,
Es ist klar, dass das dass das Markteinstiegshürden für schwächere Anbieter äh bildet und damit äh,
ja so also diese Kartellstrukturen, die sich ja sowieso unschöner Weise gerade im Internet so ein bisschen bilden, um Google herum, um Facebook herum, dass es denen einfach nur noch mehr äh noch mehr den Rücken stärkt, als sie einer äh Konkurrenzsituation im Markt auszusetzen.
Heißt eigentlich selbst so ein selbst FDP-Wähler müssten einsehen, dass das äh verboten werden müsste, aber die denken halt, dass der Markt das regelt
aber die denken die immer, insofern muss man sich da äh braucht man da jetzt nicht lange mit denen zu diskutieren. Aber ähm.
Das ist also diese dieses Spannungsfeld der
der Netzneutralität. Und in den in den USA äh gab's, glaube ich, vor zwei Jahren beschlossen, dann dieses dieses Gesetz gegen äh unbegründete Diskriminierung, was den,
unschönen Makel hatte, dass äh unbegründet nicht weiter definiert war. Das heißt, solange ich einen Grund hatte, äh war, wäre es jetzt theoretisch noch in Ordnung,
und ähm.
Du diskriminierst mich eher ja, aber ich habe auch einen Grund.
Ja, du bist ja doch Kacke.
Ja.
So und ähm,
Und außerdem das mobile Netz vollständig. Also es steht immer am Ende außer Immobiliennetz, außer Immobiliennetz, außer Mobilnetz. Ähm das hat da rein geschrieben. Die haben nämlich dieses Gesetz größtenteils zusammen mit Google ähm,
zusammen so mal vorgelegt. Ähm,
In den Niederlanden haben sie es auch gemacht und haben gesagt, äh da also da haben sie relativ stark äh starkes Netzzentralitätsgesetz. Das ging zurück auf äh Lobbybemühungen von Bits of Freedom
super äh Bürgerrechtsorganisation in in Holland. Ähm und die haben aber dann auch ihre Ausnahmen, nämlich,
um die Auswirkungen von Staus zu minimieren, wobei gleiche Arten von Datenverkehr gleich behandelt werden sollten, ist also in Ordnung, also ne, wenn, wenn man wirklich,
Stau im Internet hat,
sehr selten vor, aber wenn man den wirklich hat, dann sollte man eben sagen, okay wir wir äh bremsen komplett Port achtzig oder äh oder sonst was, ja? Und nicht wir wir blocken Port achtzig von Linus, weil der ist irgendwie nicht so cool wie Facebook,
für Maßnahmen, die die Integrität und Sicherheit des Netzes sicherstellen, ist es in Ordnung. Und,
Also wenn wenn es irgendwie den Endkunden schützt, relativ schwammige Definition, da werden sicherlich auch noch ein paar Ideen kommen, äh was unter diese Definition fällt. Ähm.
Na ja zum Beispiel, ne?
Ja genau, wunderbar, super, ja, Dedos, äh, also genau, das auch, zum Beispiel, ist ja wirklich tatsächlich im Interesse des Nutzers. Ähm,
und ähm um die Übertragung unverlangter Kommunikation,
in also Spam zum Endkunden zu beschränken, sofern der Endkunde vorher seine Einwilligung gegeben hat,
Also man macht äh man bekämpft den Spam, Slam ist ja nicht nur ein Problem für die Postfächer und die Festplatten, auf denen die Postfächer sind, sondern auch tatsächlich für die für die Kabel, durch dieser Spam die ganze Zeit bei äh geschoben wird. Ähm,
Um heute noch eine, also um heute dafür zu sorgen, dass eine Spam-E-Mail noch wirklich im Posteingang landet, muss man eine ganze Menge Traffic machen, eine ganze Menge E-Mails verschicken, bis irgendwo sie mal durch einen Spamfilter durchpurzeln.
Ähm und zuletzt, äh, zur Durchsetzung einer Rechtsvorschrift oder eines Gerichtsbeschlusses,
darf die Netzneutralität auch eingeschränkt werden und das ist auch der Grund, dass die ganzen Infos habe ich von Andre, der uns übrigens darauf hinweist, wie trotz Netzneutralitätsgesetz,
in den Niederlanden per Gerichtsbeschluss Pirate gesperrt werden darf,
also netzsperren hatte ich jetzt so komplett ausgeklammert, weil wir mit mit der Netzneutralität ja eigentlich schon so beyond, netzsperren sind.
Und ähm so schade das ist, dass man das in äh in den Niederlanden The Pirate Bake gesperrt ist,
Und zwar sowohl über IP als auch über äh DNS, das heißt, es ist wirklich schwieriger, äh da noch was zu erreichen. Ähm braucht man also VPN oder Tor? Das hat nicht jeder,
ähm muss man eigentlich sagen, dass dieses niederländische Gesetz schon,
Erstmal ein ziemlich guter Wurf ist, ja. Am liebsten wäre es natürlich, wenn man da so eine radikalere Definition hätte, aber aber mit so einem Gesetz kann man schon mal leben. Was in Deutschland gerade passiert, ist ähm,
es sieht nicht danach aus, dass wir so ein Gesetz irgendwie bekommen. Deswegen will sich der Verein digitale Gesellschaft ähm weiterhin dafür einsetzen, dass so etwas passiert.
Und ähm,
Ich fürchte so ein bisschen, dass dadurch, dass die Provider jetzt wirklich diese diese Zusatzdienst mit Rückenwind und schaut doch mal her die Nutzer wollen das. Ähm,
denke ungefähr, dass im halben Jahr die erste Zahl von der Telekom kommt und ähm,
sage ich mal, Kämpfer für die Netzneutralität gesagt wird. Freunde, äh was seid denn ihr für anachronistische Spinner? Schaut mal hier, äh die Nutzer wollen das. Hier wird mitm Geldbeutel abgestimmt
und ähm die wir können uns von Nachfragen äh an Netzneutralitätsverletzende Angebote äh kaum retten.
Ihr seid einfach irgendwelche Internetkommunisten. Das ist glaube ich das, was jetzt äh was ist die Gefahr, die ich gerade.
Netz Sozialismus gefährdet den freien Lauf der Wirtschaft. Das ist äh dann wahrscheinlich so der Tenor, hä? Schon wieder die McCashy-Ära des Internet-Zeitalters beginnt,
Und jetzt?
Ja, jetzt darf, jetzt müsst ihr euren Freunden ausreden, dass ihr dieses Spotify-Ding kaufen bei der Telekom.
Da macht man sich bestimmt total beliebt auf dem Schulhof irgendwie. Ja, wer null Punkt Facebook Punkt com eingibt, der tötet und quält auch kleine Runde. Ich weiß nicht, das kommt irgendwie nicht so an, ne?
Könnt ihr ja mal null Punkt T-Mobil DE irgendwie einführen. Das wäre vielleicht auch eine schöne Ma.
Also es ist auf ist auf jeden Fall es ist wirklich schwierig, aber ich hoffe, dass ähm bisschen
dass dass jedem klar ist, was in was für eine Welt das dann irgendwann führen wird. Also ich habe das, glaube ich, schon mal in der Sendung erwähnt, dass wir dann also es das führt dann irgendwann dazu, dass man, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht die fünfzig
größten Dienste sowieso mal irgendwie bekommt oder so und ach so, sie wollen auch noch den Rest des Internets, ja, ach wie und sie wollen auch noch mehr als Port, zweiundzwanzig, achtzig und vier, vier, drei.
Das wird teuer.
Das äh ja, nee, klar, äh haben wir auch.
Das ist auch teurer, ne? Also ich meine, da muss man ja dann dann diese Nummern auch eintragen alle und äh das kostet natürlich dann auch extrem Geld.
Das ist durchaus eine äh äh Gefahr und im Prinzip diese ganzen Portsperren,
Man schon, ne? Also in dem Moment, wo welche sind, also gerade so an Universitäten, kriege ich immer wieder das Frösteln, wenn man da mal so sieht, wie da so die hausinternen Netze äh zugenagelt sind, also auch nach draußen. Was man da alles nicht benutzen kann,
Angst haben, ja? Also irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl so Systemadministratoren von Universitätsnetzwerken, müsste man mal mit so einem so,
so Traumamedikamenten irgendwie behandeln, weil die irgendwie in so einem so einer permanenten Schockstarre zu sein scheinen, dass sie einfach irgendwie alles zumachen, was in irgendeiner Form äh gefährlich aussieht,
Ja, also Gott, wir fangen dann tatsächlich an, hier noch das Netz zu benutzen und so. Und äh
machen es dann auch so zu, dass man noch nicht mal die Chance hat, mit einem VPN irgendwie dem zu entgehen,
absurd finde, ja? Ja, ich bin ja bereit, euer Netz komplett zu ignorieren und ihr müsst mir hier irgendwie nur so ein kleines Wurmloch äh äh bieten, wo ich an einer anderen Stelle das Universum wieder rauskomme und das darf ich dann auch nicht.
Also ich meine da frage ich mich, warum sie überhaupt Internet anbieten, wenn sie das eigentlich gar nicht anbieten wollen.
Fragen die sich glaube ich selbst.
Das ist schlimm.
Aber Universitäten, also habe ich in Universitäten habe ich die Erfahrung nicht so gemacht. Ich habe da immer ganz gutes Netz in der in der Universität, die ich besucht habe. Ja, nee, das war super. Ja, war spitze.
Ernsthaft? Mhm. Hundert Mbit.
Ja, so lange ist das auch nicht her, dass ich studiert habe.
Haut mich jetzt nicht grade besonders um. Ach so, du meinst so richtig Internet, äh hundert MB zwo. Ah ja, okay.
Das war und und und eine eine richtige IP, echtes IP for f.
Ui ui ui.
Ja und wollte ich noch ganz kurz natürlich mich drüber aufregen, äh hat damit jetzt gar nichts zu tun, aber äh du hattest die Asynchronität des des VDSL und des DSL angesprochen. Und ähm,
ich sehe da so eine, also wir kriegen ja die ganze Zeit so äh also mein VDSL Anschluss zum Beispiel fünfzig MB Down, zehn Mbit Up,
Da fühle ich mich einfach nicht als gleichberechtigter Teilnehmer des Internets. Wenn ich nicht so viel da rein die Reihen nicht so schnell da rein kann, wie die anderen äh bei mir rein. Und das finde ich nicht gut. Bei Kabel Deutschland ist das noch schlimmer, ähm hundert Mbit sechs MB,
lässt sich natürlich besser bewerben, weil keine Saufrad nach dem Upload außer die Leute hier im Raume so wenn man sagt, hier du kriegst hundert MB Internet, ja hundert Mbit Internet, super, will man haben.
Es war mal erstaunlich, wie selten die das auch wissen, also wenn man mal fragt, geht's mal in irgendeinen beliebigen Mobilfunkladen rein oder überhaupt der dir äh Internet verkauft? Dann so, ja hier total schnell und so, ja, was ist so der Abstream? Ja der,
ist denn nochmal gleich? Da muss ich mal kurz im Glossar nachschlagen.
Also lässt sich besser bewerben, manifestiert irgendwie auch so eine Ungleichheit im Netze und ähm entspricht aber leider dem Nutzungsverhalten, denn ein äh enger Vertrauter von mir stellte einmal fest, ich lade sehr selten Poren ins Internet hoch.
Wirklich? Hm. Das sollte einem zu denken geben, ja. Stimmt eigentlich. Brauchen wir das ja eigentlich auch gar nicht.
Es ist die Frage, wenn wir also, wenn wir irgendwie so ein so ein Facebook Internetkonsum, Tenniscreen haben wollen, dann ist das völlig okay so, dann wird das keiner merken. Und ähm dann voran voran. Wenn wir das irgendwie anders haben wollen, dann müssen wir uns da was einfallen lassen.
Okay. Ist das schon dein Schlusswort?
Am liebsten mit diesem, ich lade selten Porno ins Internet hochgeendet, aber.
Entschuldigung, dann habe ich da wieder drauf geantwortet, ne. Schlimm, schlimm, schlimm. Aber.
Muss ich ja immer erwähnen. Respekt, mein Net, da kann man äh da äh Respekt manet kann man petzen über nicht ähm nicht neutrale Internetanschlüsse und da gibt's eine Reihe an Tools zur Selbstdiagnose Tools, bei denen man seinen ähm,
seine eigenen Internetanschluss auf Neutralität prüfen kann. Ähm wird gemacht äh von so ein paar Leuten aus dem Umfeld von äh Lackfarateuret, französische Gruppe zum zur Freiheit des Netzes.
Mhm. Schönes Ding. Ja, Linus. Machen wir's, oder? Schon bisschen, äh, bisschen strange, aber wir könnten uns ja jetzt auch künftig immer ähm so ein Hundertschaft ins Studio einladen, irgendwie.
Sonntags irgendwie in den Mauerpark setzen, machen wir Open, Mic oder so.
Ja. Fand ich jetzt aber gar nicht mal so schlimm.
Ja, ich habe die ganze Zeit da hinten so in die Ecke geguckt, da sitzt keiner.
Ja. Ja, dann würde ich sagen, tüten wir mal die Sendung hier ein bisschen ein. Das war's. Und wir sind ja dann sozusagen auch gleich oder das Publikum muckt auf, was möchtest du? Fragen?
Hat eine Frage. Wenn, wo Kami eine Frage hat, kann ich die nicht beantworten.
Ach, der will sich jetzt hier doch als Gast äh ja, aber das Problem ist, dass wir jetzt äh kriegen wir das hinein mikrofoniert hier.
Wir haben halt eigentlich gesagt bekommen, wir sollen uns hier um viertel nach äh.
Ich würde sagen, wir tüten jetzt hier erst mal die Sendung ein und äh die Fragesession gibt's dann als.
Frage machen wir einfach direkt im Anschluss.
Die gibt's dann sozusagen als als Bonustrack äh auf dem Internet äh jetzt machen wir hier erstmal äh die Sendung vorbei, oder?
Okay, wir machen erstmal. Ja, wir machen Schluss und machen eine Fragerunde.
Genau, das war's. Dann tschüss.